First of all, thank you so much
for taking time to come and visit here.
Really, thank you.
Time is precious.
Thanks for having us.
Thank you.
Really, thank you.
Now Elaine, you just were here visiting,
thank you so much.
And I did get to do the butt shimmy with you.
We did, virtually.
We felt the love.
We did it.
I still can't get that virtual frame up perfectly.
But you have every media outlet
that you've tapped into,
you're an incredible writer,
you have a best-selling book.
I mean, how is this as a platform for you?
Well, this is an incredible opportunity.
To be amongst these women every single day,
for us to have this bond,
that is kind of instant,
and it feels built-in.
This family feels built-in.
It's just an extraordinary dream job come true.
And I think in this moment of real division
in our country,
for us to be bridge builders every single day
is really, really important and special,
and I don't take it for granted.
And we have fun too, by the way.
I have to tell you, these women keep me laughing.
I'm crying my eyelashes off half the time
on the commercial break.
They're just the best.
That's 'cause you're naughty.
(women laughing)
I'm a little naughty too.
She's not lying.
I think that we're all blessed to have a platform.
Because that's what this is.
We have a platform every day to be ourselves,
to talk about what's going on,
and to do it with a whole group of great women,
it's like a gift.
And Drew, I tried to do this on my own,
and it's the toughest gig in the world.
People don't realize how hard it is to do it on your own,
so I bow down to you.
Seriously.
For doing it on your own.
Well, I mean, first of all,
you've been such a success in so many areas,
and a pioneer.
"The Osbournes" hadn't really been done,
and I was married to Tom Green,
and I love that I thought he kicked off like a new genre.
Like you can't do that on television,
or you know, candid camera,
and you really were at the forefront
of a complete societal, cultural, generational shift.
And I've seen you tackle so many things.
And then Sheryl, I've really been comforted
by the things you've said,
because I like to be funny and go for it,
and get a laugh, or go for the joke,
and you know, when you're writing crickets on tumbleweeds,
that's a little more difficult.
(women laughing)
Right?
And you're a real comedian.
I mean, do you feel like that some authenticity
has like seeped in because you can't go for the funny
or are you like still excited
for that audience to come back.
What has been the shift and change for you?
Well, we still have the audience, it's the cameraman.
It's the grip, it's everybody on the floor,
it's the floor managers, the stage managers,
all the producers, but it's also these ladies right here.
If I can't make these four broads laugh,
then I'm really not doing my job.
(women laughing)
And I really like when Sharon spits out
whatever's in her cup.
So I've done it.
And any time Carrie Ann kicks her heels up
to show her underwear-
What?
That is a standing ovation.
I never do that.
Yes, you do.
I get it.
Never!
And then I love that Amanda and Elaine,
they're trying to hold it in and they can't.
And Carrie Ann, I bet you do like dance around.
I had no idea that you were a back up dancer for Madonna.
I freaked out learning that.
I'm going straight to my inner Madonna
freak out Valley girl.
That was a long time ago.
And back then I used to not wear clothes
and I had no hair.
So it was a different day.
But yeah, it was a lot of fun back in the day.
I heard she made you shave it.
She was like, if you wanna be on this tour,
you'll shave that head.
She did, she lined all of the dancers up
and the final question was,
you guys are doing really well,
but will you shave your head bald?
And I was like, for you, absolutely, yeah.
Of course, you don't pass up that.
Well, speaking of great women,
I also loved reading about your aunties
and how much female community meant to you growing up
and what a perfect fit a show like this.
You know what, female community, as we all know,
is so important.
Being on this show is like basically the way I was grown up.
I was grown up with strong women always giving advice.
And that's what we do here.
We all share our stories, when we have problems,
like when we've had a bad show,
or a show that we didn't think we did well,
we reach out to each other,
we get feedback.
When we're going through our own personal problems,
what's amazing is we have this built-in community
of resources that really helps,
and on all aspects, and it's so beautiful
to share it online for those people at home
that maybe don't know what a girl group is like,
to have girlfriends,
we can be their girlfriends,
and we also encourage them to show them
how to be good girlfriends.
You listen to each other and you support each other
even when you have different points of views.
That's right.
Well, I have really loved trying to get to know you,
Amanda, through everything that you've put out there
especially in the last year,
you seem like a person who not only is so strong,
and has been someone that we've watched
go through a journey,
and yet you've opened yourself up
and extended yourself in ways,
you seem like the nicest, most loving,
respectful, spiritual, incredible person
who I'm so glad that you found yourself
in this community of amazing, strong women.
I can't think of anyone who deserves that community
more than you do.
Oh, thank you so much.
It's so nice to meet you.
I am such a big fan of yours.
But no, you did say it exactly right, Drew.
I feel so lucky to be here.
To get to come to work every day.
To have something to do.
But not only that, to have this family
it just means the world to me,
it really, really does.
I try to be a light in the world,
and those are my daily goals.
So that means the world to me.
And I just try to surround myself with good people
'cause I think that's a good thing to try to do.
And to then be a good person.
So thank you for saying that.
Well, it's so evident.
(upbeat music)